for the current power sources and its
current use cases what's the use case
for electric
like the the the corloid engine
can you talk about where they're used
today sure
so chemical engines are still used
um quite a bit once you're in orbit but
that's
also where you might choose instead to
use an electric system
and what people do with them and
and this includes you know the ion
engines and health thrusters and our
engine
is basically any maneuvering you need to
do once you're dropped off
um there's even if your only goal was to
just
stay in your orbit and not move for the
life of your mission
you need propulsion to accomplish that
because the
earth's gravity field changes as you go
around in orbit and
pulls you out of your little box um
there are other
perturbations um that that can throw you
off a bit
and then you know most people want to do
things a little bit more interesting
like
maneuver to avoid being hit by space
debris
or perhaps lower their orbit to take a
higher resolution image of something and
then return
at the end of your mission you're
supposed to responsibly get rid of your
satellite whether that's
burning it up but if you're in geo you
want to push it higher into graveyard
orbit
um what's geo what's um so low earth
orbit and then geosynchronous orbit or
geostationary orbit
and there's a graveyard yeah so those
satellites are at
like 40 000 kilometers so if they were
to try to push
their satellites back down to burn up in
the atmosphere
they would need you know even more
propulsion than they've had for the
whole lifetime of their mission
so instead they push them higher where
it'll take you know a million years for
it to naturally
de-orbit um so we're also cluttering
that
higher bit up as well but it's not as
pressing as
as leo which is low earth orbit where
more of these commercial missions are
going now cool so
how hard is the collision avoidance
problem there he said some debris and
stuff so like
how much propulsion is needed like how
much is the the life of a satellite is
just like
oh crap trying trying to avoid like
literally i think one of the recent
um you know rules of thumb i heard was
per year some of these small satellites
are doing like three
collision avoidance maneuvers um so
that's that's
good yeah but it's not zero um and it
yeah it takes a lot of um planning and
people on the ground
and you know none of that really i don't
think right now is autonomous
oh that's not good yeah and then we have
a lot of folks
taking advantage of you know moore's
lawn cheaper spacecraft so they're
launching them up without the ability to
maneuver themselves and they're like
well
i don't know just don't hit me and three
times a year that could be become
affordable if it's like
if it gets hit maybe it won't be damaged
kind of thing
that kind of logic affordable in that
instead of launching one satellite
they'll launch you know 20 small ones
yeah so if one gets taken out
that's okay but the problem is that you
know one good-sized satellite getting
hit
um that's like a ballistic event that
turns into 10 000 pieces of debris that
then
are the things that go and hit the other
satellites yeah
you